okay we are now going to look at an
example of the United States under
Donald Trump becoming reminiscent of
sort of a weird mishmash of George
Orwell's 1984 and Aldous Huxley's brave
new world I've talked about the
differences between those two books and
this example is sort of a combination of
the two vice president Mike Pence is now
defending the deficits that Trump first
said he would eliminate and later
pretended weren't actually ballooning
Mike Pence now saying that the deficits
are part of the massive economic growth
pet plan that Donald Trump is running
with in the economy with this story we
can essentially agree never to talk
about debt and deficit again if we don't
want to because it is almost like satire
Saturday Night Live level defense of the
deficits that they say are terrible when
it's a Democratic president that they
said they would eliminate that they
claimed didn't explode under Trump even
though they did and now they are saying
right yeah well the deficit is up and
it's part of our plan and ultimately
it's all gonna work out here is Mike
Pence on CNBC making this case and we're
going to do this as another sort of
disinformation propaganda debunking
where we'll go bit by bit
because there's so much here that's
important to not allow yourself to be
tricked with so let's look at the first
clip to start with the economy certainly
the numbers are very strong and and that
the unemployment numbers in particular
very impressive I wonder whether you
feel though a little bit of the gloss of
that impressiveness needs to be removed
because of the deficit that the size of
the deficit in the direction that its
it's heading well we saw in the last
administration that a doubling of the
national debt okay so we actually have
to stop it already
this guy's sick this guy's a sick liar
did you notice the bait and switch there
pence was asked about the deficit which
has exploded under Donald Trump and Mike
Pence said you know under Obama the debt
doubled this is a bait and switch and it
only works if you are an uninformed
person on this issue the deficit is the
one-year deficit or surplus for that
year's budget that adds to or takes away
from the national debt if you go into a
year with $100 in debt and run a ten
dollar deficit your debt at the end of
that second year becomes a hundred and
ten dollars if in the next year you
reduce the deficit to eight dollars
you've reduced the deficit by 20% from
ten dollars to eight dollars but you've
accumulated another eight dollars in
total debt meaning at the end of year
two you now have a hundred and eighteen
dollars in debt a president can slow
deficit growth or reverse it
but that can even still not pay off the
debt in four years or even eight years
so Barack Obama drastically slowed
deficit growth but of course if you have
a deficit at all the debt keeps
accumulating year over year pence was
asked about the deficit going up under
Donald Trump which it did and Pence says
the debt went up under Barack Obama he's
a sick liar let's continue a doubling of
the national debt but we also saw an
American economy that wasn't growing by
more than two percent it was the slowest
economic recovery since the Great
Depression okay so they claim again
Obama's recovery was a recovery but it
was a very slow recovery it wasn't
really a good one this is also a lie the
stock market during Barack Obama's first
three years performed better than the
stock market during Donald Trump's first
three years deficit growth slowed under
Obama deficit growth exploded under
Donald Trump job creation at the end of
Barack Obama's presidency was actually
stronger than what Trump has had so far
we're gonna deal with that on tomorrow
or Wednesday's program so even more lies
let's continue because this continues to
build up to this idea that oh no the
deficits are just part of the growth
plan that we have and the president came
into office and he said first and
foremost we have to restore growth
that's how we will deal with the
long-term fiscal challenges facing our
country and deficits and debt are right
in line but it's first about getting
this economy moving again and and we
really do believe the trajectory of this
we're gonna end the next year in the 3%
range which is what President Trump said
back on the campaign trail in 2016 so
now Mike Pence is claiming Trump
promised 3% GDP growth and the reason
that he's doing this
make no mistake is because they just got
the 2019 numbers and it was 2.9 percent
GDP growth so now Pence says Trump
promised 3 this is a lie Trump promised
four five and even 6 percent GDP growth
during the campaign he promised it after
being in office check out just one
example of this get it going the way I
really want where we have GDP getting up
to four or five and even 6% because I
think that's possible if you look back
in your notes you'll say when I say 4%
people said that would be years well it
turns out that I'm right because without
the Hurricanes this last quarter we
would have had poor person Mike Pence is
pretending that Trump promised three and
that they hit it or almost hit that goal
it's lies lies lies Trump promised four
Trump promised five Trump promised six
so now we are finally getting to the
conclusion and you will notice that
pence doesn't even use the language
deficit and debt
he just keeps referring to fiscal
challenges and he says growth is how we
will deal with fiscal challenges he's
finally acknowledging the deficit
explosion without actually saying he's
acknowledging it and saying growth is
the plan deficit as a percentage of GDP
though has has ticked up each year of
this first term would you like to see it
as a focus for the second term if you
win want to change the direction of that
well I think the president's been very
clear and we've we've sharpened our
pencils on our budgets and will continue
to do that and in a second term we'll
continue to address those issues but but
President Trump really believes that the
real long-term solution to the fiscal
challenges in Washington DC is making
sure that the budget of every American
is growing and you know real income
after tax income for working families
it's actually increased by $5,000 a year
in the last three years and so the
president's going to stay focused on a
growing American economy
and once we get this economy rolling
we're gonna continue to hold Congress to
account and we're gonna work real hard
not just to get President Donald Trump
four more years in the White House but
we're gonna make sure that we have a
Republican Senate and a Republican House
to keep America growing and to deal with
those long term fiscal challenges so
look at this for decades Republicans say
the deficits terrible we've got to get a
surplus we've got to pay off the debt
we've got to cut everything and cut our
way out of debt Trump actually promises
to pay off the debt within eight years
only the most uninformed person would
buy that as a real possibility
unfortunately many of his voters were
uninformed and they bought it the
deficit explodes Trump says well the
growth that my tax cuts are going to
stimulate will reduce the deficit
doesn't happen does the tax cuts blows
up the deficit anyway
the growth doesn't happen they deny that
the deficit has exploded now they can't
deny it anymore so they say well this is
all part of the plan and the eventual
growth that the tax cuts are going to
cause is going to deal with it no
economist worth worth their weight in
salt
never mind Gould believes that that's
going to happen they have lost the right
to ever talk about the debt and deficit
again Republicans in Washington care
about the deficit when the president is
a Democrat and they stopped caring two
seconds after a Republican is in the in
the Oval Office this has been happening
for a long time I believe it started
under under Reagan if not before and if
you look at this from a political
standpoint why would they stop I mean
it's it's completely inconsistent it's
complete hypocrisy but it doesn't hurt
them when it's useful to them to talk
about debt and deficit if a Democrat is
the president or if they want to claim
that they are going to pay this off or
pay that off then they just do it and
they get rewarded for it rewarded for it
electoral e then they blow up the
deficit and in some way they justified
and people are either too stupid or
willingly ignorant and they just go
along with it with Bush it was like
we'll listen you know we had to do this
Iraq war and that that was expensive we
did what do you mean we had to do it we
went after a country that had nothing to
do with 9/11 and had no WMDs that was
the real what we had to do it what are
you talking about
under Trump either
you deny it's happening as is
increasingly popular at least with my
trumpet followers they say now that the
debts the deficit is not up yet is
theirs just fine the reports that's
public information or they say in the
longer term in the medium term the
reasons that we have a larger deficit
now are going to create all this growth
and it'll all work out which is just not
happening it's been years already and
it's just not going to happen why would
they stop doing it when it continues to
be useful to them electorally they won't
stop doing